so the search continues for the believed
mar-a-lago traitor slash mole slash
leaker whatever this is the story the
belief wherein
uh there are some in the maga right who
believe that the only way the fbi could
have known where to look and what to do
during this search warrant would have
been if there were some mole within
magaland and many names have been
floated everything from some secret
service agent to some employee at
mar-a-lago all the way to mark meadows
now i don't know for sure that it's
clear there is such a mall because there
are also claims
that donald trump personally gave fbi
agents a tour of mar-a-lago some months
ago and might even have shown them
exactly where everything is we just
don't know if there is a so-called mole
at mar-a-lago but increasingly there are
reports that donald trump is being
driven nuts that's a quote driven nuts
not knowing who the mole is according to
an ex-federal prosecutor and others have
made similar claims and one of the
things that is being made very very
clear by donald trump's lawyer alina
habba
is that
they're going to find who the mole is
they're going gonna figure out who it is
and then all bets are off another one of
these thinly veiled threats
take a listen to alina haba appearing on
uh i believe this is on newsmax and it's
the typical mob speak that we've become
very accustomed to in the trump era the
president's position the same as what i
would advise him is to
ask them to uncover everything so that
we can see what is going on i understand
the witness protection issue but at the
same time these witnesses are truly not
going to be um
concealed for very long that's just not
the nature of the doj and the fbi
they're gonna figure out who you are
eventually this is the typical
mob speak that we've gotten accustomed
to
from trumpists this is either
just more insanity
or
a warning a threat
to the informant if they even exist how
are they suppose listen
alina haba wants to know how do we
intimidate a witness when we don't know
who the witness is we need to be told
who that witness is and there is no
question whatsoever that if there is
such a mole and if indeed their identity
becomes public that the mega trump right
is going to go absolutely nuts i mean
listen they're going after fbi agents
merrick garland is receiving death
threats christopher wray who was
selected to run the fbi by trump who
signed off on the search warrant
uh he is getting death threats these
people are vicious these people are
violent january 6th prove that to us and
so i understand the concern if such a
mole exists i understand why they would
rather not be known and everybody is in
mega world is melting down and that's
what i want to talk about next
one of our sponsors is little spoon your
one stop shop for healthy easy meals and
snacks for your baby toddler or big kid
delivered right to your door with fresh
organic baby food for every stage
toddler and kids meals that even the
picky eaters will love
and the new line of healthy smoothies
little spoon has you covered little
spoon makes everything fresh it's just
like homemade it's ready in mere moments
all of the recipes are delicious they're
nutritionally balanced and free of junk
little spoons baby food is 100 organic
and cold pressed for every eating stage
for toddlers and kids little spoon has
the classics mac and cheese but they'll
sneak things in like butternut squash
and carrots they have more adventurous
meals cheesy pupusas or chicken pot
stickers they're all kid approved packed
with nutrients and little spoons organic
smoothies are perfect when you need
something quick and easy and the best
part is kids meals under six dollars and
baby food and smoothies under three
dollars each plus you'll get 50 off your
first order when you go to
littlespoon.com and use the coupon code
pacman50 the link is down below